farmer kimyong bin also runs a
Distillery business on the side making
rice wines he can be proud of working
near the demilitarized zone or the DMZ
as it's widely known means he sees the
highs and lows of crossb
relations if there's military skirmishes
farmers are forced to suspend their work
and Retreat to safety if the situation
worsens younger people will leave and
the population will reduce making it an
even harder place to live for us peace
is a critical need for our daily lives a
monor rail ride to a former US military
Outpost offers a unique vantage point a
rare Glimpse over the DMZ and into North
Korea centrally located on the Korean
Peninsula this former transport Hub used
to be bustling with activity until Korea
was divided what you see behind me is
White Horse Hill the site of one of the
fiercest battles of the Korean war
changing hands dozens of times and
sustaining massive casualties by both
the Chinese Army and UN forces the
battlefields are now rice patties where
only registered farmers and visitors are
allowed a few kilometers away on the
other side of a forest stands a North
Korean town satellite imagery shows a
statue in pongyang built by North
Korea's founding ruler to celebrate
reunification one day now demolished to
erase that hope after an order last week
from leader Kim Chun back in the South a
town in the Border County of chadan
rebuilt to show what life was like in
decades past Waits For Tourists along
with a lasting peace which remains ever
elusive on the Korean Peninsula Unis Kim
aljazera chadan South
Korea make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer